the ultimate
question of of from physics is
okay so we have this abstract model of
the universe
why does the universe exist at all
right so you know we might say there is
a a
formal model that if you run this model
you get the universe or the model gives
you
you know a model of the universe right
you you you run this mathematical thing
and the mathematics unfolds in the way
that corresponds to the universe
but the question is why was that
actualized
why does the actual universe actually
exist
and um so this is this is another one of
these humility and
in um is like can you figure this out i
have a guess
okay about the answer to that and um my
guess is somewhat unsatisfying
but my guess is that it's a little bit
similar to girdle second and
completeness theorem
which is the statement that from within
as an axiomatic theory like
piano arithmetic you cannot from within
that theory
prove the consistency of the theory so
my guess is that for entities within the
universe
there is no finite determination that
can be made
of the the statement the universe exists
is essentially undecidable to any entity
that is embedded in the universe within
that universe how does that make you
feel
is that is that does that put you at
peace that it's impossible
or is it really ultimately frustrating
well i think it just says
that it's not a kind of question that
you know it's there are things that it
is reasonable i mean
that there's kinds of you know you can
talk about hyper computation as well you
can say
imagine there was a hyper computer
here's what it would do it's okay great
it would be lovely to have a hyper
computer but unfortunately we can't make
it in the universe
like it would be lovely to answer this
but unfortunately we can't do it in the
universe
um and you know this is all we have so
to speak
um and i think it's it's really just a a
statement
it's sort of in the end it'll be a kind
of a logical
logically inevitable statement i think i
think it will be something where
it is as you understand what it means to
have
what it means to have a sort of
predicate of existence and what it means
to have these kinds of things that will
sort of be inevitable
that this has to be the case that from
within that universe you can't
establish the reason for its existence
so to speak you can't prove that it
exists and so on
and nevertheless because of
computational reducibility
the future is uh ultimately not
predictable full of mystery and that's
what makes
life worth living right i mean right and
you know
it's funny for me because as a pure sort
of human being doing what i do
it's you know i'm i'm uh you know i like
i'm interested in people i like
sort of the you know the whole human
experience so to speak
and yet it's a little bit weird when i'm
thinking
you know it's all hypergraphs down there
and it's all just
uh hyper graphs all the way down right
it's like turtles all the way down
yeah yeah right and and it's kind of you
know it's
to me it is a funny thing because every
so often i get this
you know as i'm thinking about i think
we've really gotten you know we've
really figured out kind of the essence
of how physics works and i'm
like thinking to myself you know here's
this physical thing and i'm like
you know this feels like a very definite
thing how can it be the case that this
is just some real reference frame
of you know this infinite creature that
that is
uh so abstract and so on and i kind of
it is a
it's a it's a funny sort of feeling that
that
you know we are we're sort of uh um
it's like it's in the end it's just sort
of um we're just going to be happy we're
just humans
and it's kind of like but but we're
making we make things
as it's not like we're just a tiny speck
we are
in a sense the we are more important
by virtue of the fact that in a sense
it's not like there's there is no
ultimate
you know it's like we're important
because
because you know we're here so to speak
and we're not
it's not like there's a thing where
we're saying um
you know we are just but one sort of
intelligence out of all these other
intelligences
and so you know ultimately they'll be
the super intelligence which is
all of these put together and it'll be
very different from us no it's actually
going to be equivalent to us
and the thing that makes us a sort of
special
is just the details of us so to speak
it's not something where we can say
oh there's this other thing you know
just you think humans are cool
just wait until you've seen this you
know it's going to be much more
impressive
well no it's all going to be kind of
computationally equivalent
and the thing that you know it's not
going to be oh this thing is
is amazingly much more impressive and
amazingly much more
meaningful let's say no we're it
i mean that's that's that that's the um
and the symbolism of this particular
moment
so this has been one of the one of
the favorite conversations i've ever had
steven
it's a huge honor to talk to you to talk
about a topic like this
for four plus hours on the fundamental
theory of physics
and yet we're just two finite
descendants of
apes that have to end this conversation
because darkness have
come upon us right and we're going to
get bitten by mosquitoes and kinds of
symbolism of that we're talking about
the most
basic fabric of reality and having to
end
because of the fact that things end um
it's tragic and beautiful stephen thank
you so much
huge honor i can't wait to see what you
do in the next couple of days and next
week a month
we're all watching with excitement thank
you so much thanks
you